bonjour et bienvenue dans reporter
l'émission deux grands reportages de la
rédaction de france 24 le 19 mars 1962
la france et l'algérie signent les
accords d'evian un cessez le feu qui
ouvre la voie vers l'indépendance
mais la transition se fera dans la
douleur et la violence loes
l'organisation armée secrète refusent
ces accords les pieds noirs sont
contraints de fuir l'algérie alors que
la france abandonne à leur sort des
milliers de harkis soixante ans après
nous avons retrouvé les témoins les
acteurs de cette date clé dans
l'histoire des deux pays un document
signé georges yazbek nesrine ben
zemmouchi et karim rihaoui
[Musique]
un bâtiment chic sur les rives paisibles
du lac léman
cette résidence privée était autrefois
l'hôtel du parc
aucune plaque aucune indication
pourtant l'histoire franco-algérienne ya
connu un moment décisif
[Musique]
à et vient sous les fenêtres de l'hôtel
du parc
la tempête du lac s'est apaisée symbole
peut-être est tour à tour belkacem krim
et la délégation fln louis joxe et la
délégation française se sont encore une
fois retrouvée mais cette fois pour
conclure
la paix enfin après sept années et demie
d'une guerre cruelle et interminable
pourtant beaucoup avaient espéré qu'elle
s'achève bien avant date charnière pour
la france c'est 59-16 759 de gaulle à la
télévision dit que on va s'orienter vers
l'autodétermination
je m'engage
à consulter
les algériens
douze départements
au sujet du testeur qu'ils veulent
adopter et ça ça a été compris à ce
moment là comme une marche vers
l'indépendance
j'étais enfant en algérie comme mon père
et a été envoyé comme professeur j'étais
sous lieutenant l'algérie pendant la
guerre et en 16 70 59 on a cru que la
guerre était finie donc comme vous le
savez les négociations des viandes
commencé à aboutir que
[Musique]
printemps 62 le père de pierre joxe
louis joxe sera la tête de la délégation
française qui négociera les accords
d'evian mais entre la déclaration du
général de gaulle et les accords de
cessez-le-feu la guerre va redoubler
d'intensité entre 1959 et 1961 le plan
challe vise à poser la puissance
militaire française face aux combattants
de la ln
mais de gaulle pouvait-il vraiment aller
plus vite sur le chemin de la paix
comment elle est arrivée au pouvoir
était au pouvoir par des généraux au nom
de la jeune française s'y prend cette
position maintenant c'est devenu le
putsch en france
dans ce contexte de violence extrême les
négociations continuent quand même
l'armée française engrange les succès
militaires mais la guerre d'algérie de
plus en plus difficile à défendre
politiquement
en 1961 à evian non loin de la frontière
suisse un nouveau round de négociations
suscite de nouveaux espoirs
sur le territoire helvète à la
réputation de neutralité le fln a trouvé
une base arrière propice aux discussions
avec les autorités françaises
ben je m'appelle un vrai gazon
et je suis arrivé en suisse en 1960
d'une manière un peu particulière
puisque je venais de le déserter
andré gazut à déserter horrifiés par la
torture il a trouvé refuge en suisse où
il est embauché par la télévision
publique en 61 ans j'ai réussi j'ai été
un des premiers à pouvoir être admis à
bois davos où il y avait à la délégation
du gpra il était arrivé dans un avion
swissair depuis tunis et y résider dans
ce site de bois davo gardés par l'armée
suisse avec des canons des ca par
crainte de bombardements par un petit
avion
low as
bien sûr il faut quand même pas oublier
que
le maire de déviants venait d'être
assassiné
par les gens de l'algérie française l
enquête se poursuit pour tenter de
retrouver les auteurs de l'attentât
d'evian qui coûta la vie au maire de la
ville monsieur camille blanc et blessa
légèrement sa femme les enquêteurs
examinent actuellement les quelques
pièces du dossier lettre de menaces de
toutes sortes expliqué presque toutes
d'algérie et donc moi je me suis
retrouvé à lundi 5 juin à bois davost
pour moi c'était assez incroyable de me
retrouver face à des négociateurs le
bonheur
peut-être cette guerre va se terminer
hélas les négociations d'evian de miro
un sens achevé
sans conclusion ils ne peuvent vivre en
je suis jeté à l'époque camier les
jeunes
dont le titulaire était louis joxe et
vient se dérouler en plusieurs stades
premiers evian les belkacem a bien posé
deux principes qu'ils étaient des lignes
rouges
l'unité du peuple qui s'opposaient à ce
qu'on fasse à statut spécial pour les
pleinement et puis l'unité du territoire
il pas question que vous demanderiez
l'égérie en la privant des départements
sarria sapa marché prenait je prenais
région parce que nous on s'est accroché
à ça mais apple savez douter le putsch
la perspective d'une algérie
indépendante est inconcevable pour
certains gradés de l'armée française en
avril 1961 ils tentent de renverser le
pouvoir gaulliste
l'armée vous parle vous avez devant vous
les généraux challe joue les élèves le
13 mai l'armée française avait fait le
serment solennel
de garder l'algérie dans la souveraineté
française
ce serment
nous voulons aujourd'hui au nom de
l'armée vous le renouveler les boutisme
et réussi à mobiliser de l'argent parce
qu ils avaient tous des transistors il
faut écouter ce qu'on disait à paris les
appels de général à résister à ce putsch
donc le push a échoué ensuite de sa le
général cocou qu il ne commencera pas je
ne bois jamais
vous avez
un avis à donner sur
l'avenir des négociations
du général oui ce qu'elle choisit jamais
des algériens renoncement que ça il faut
qu'ils aient la souveraineté si vous le
faites place à mashhad
j'ai été agréablement
surpris d'entendre la conférence de
presse qu'il jure plus tard et pour
un jour à la souvent sur le ca nous
sommes prêts à la reconnaître mais il
nous faut des 40
l'accord sur la question du sahara
débloque des négociations qui menaçait
encore une fois de s'enliser alors que
le général de gaulle se montrait de plus
en plus pressant avec ses négociateurs
le cessez-le-feu signé le 18 et entre en
vigueur le 19 mars 1962 à midi l'algérie
elle l'est au forceps ne s'est pas le
simple transfert tout français comme ça
comme en tunisie ou au maroc et
cherchent à quitter
ces lieux les algériens obtiennent
également gain de cause sur une question
fondamentale à leurs yeux il n'y aura
pas de statut particulier pour les
européens
on voulait donner un million d'européens
nationaliste ya lieu
tout en
charge est un état dans l'état
nous avions le fuji
un référendum d'autodétermination
sera organisée dans les trois mois une
algérie où l'égalité des droits des
citoyens sera garanti doit voir le jour
qui s'ouvre sur l'avènement d'une
algérie
étroitement avec nous
ça qui font la raison
la france obtient une concession pour 15
ans de la base militaire de
mers-el-kébir et elle pourra continuer
ses expérimentations nucléaires dans le
sahara jusqu'en 1966 quant aux immenses
réserves de pétrole du pays l'algérie en
devient propriétaire mais c'est la
france qui en aura la gestion pendant
plusieurs années
la signature des accords marque un
immense soulagement en métropole
je suis bien content d'un côté parce que
je pars bientôt faire mon service
militaire et je pense vers saint-émilion
j'ai passé une chance de résister à la
rochelle des choses qu'on devait faire
et bien c'est un cauchemar qui se
termine quoi depuis le temps que ça
durait depuis sept ans c'était un peu
long c'est un bien stovall
[Musique]
afin d'alléger votre famille en algérie
win thin et vous craignez pour m moi je
crains tu pourrais aussi
la crainte du pouvoir gaulliste à
l'époque c'était que la guerre la guerre
d'algérie reprennent donc il a encouragé
les
laisser représentants dans ces
négociations a lâché tout le plus vite
possible sans contrepartie réelle et
sans se donner les moyens et le temps
pour organiser le
organiser le passage un état côté fln on
appelle alors à la vigilance le 6 et le
feu d'abord la paix a juste par exemple
sont là et la violence
si
low as multiplient les attentats et les
meurtres le fln répliquent par des
assassinats et des enlèvements les
commando de l'organisation armée secrète
affrontent l'armée française dans une
guérilla urbaine meurtrière
déjà avant attaqué par des commandos as
les troupes ripostait dans les rues
étroites ont tiré des terrasses sur les
crs qui établissent et leur quadrillage
ou dénombré trois morts on comptait 66
blessés
le 26 mars une manifestation pro aux as
dégénère à l'entrée du quartier de bab
el oued
[Musique]
le bilan est très lourd des dizaines de
morts est un tournant dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de pieds noirs qu'on a fait
tirer
sur des français
pour les
preuves que wes avait raison en disant
c'est la valise ou le cercueil
les accords promettait une algérie
multiculturelle mais durant cette
période de transition entre mai et juin
62 des centaines de milliers de français
fui l'algérie en juin le fln et l'oas
finissent par signer un accord
rapidement désavoué et malgré l'appel du
fln l'exode des pieds noirs continuent
irrémédiable
algérien d'origine européenne
au nom de tous mes frères algériens
je vous dis que si vous le voulez
les pertes de l'avenir s'ouvre à vous
pour manu notre peuple dans sa sagesse à
supporter tant des peurs que ce soir que
demain
cesse les dernières violences
mais des violences vont continuer et
s'inviter le jour même de l'indépendance
le référendum prévu par les accords
d'evian est une formalité plus de 99%
des votants choisissent l'indépendance
mais le 5 juillet à oran la fête
nationale est endeuillée des coups de
feu partent c'est la panique on
soupçonnera l' os au coeur de la cité
alors que l'excitation date est son
plein une fusillade avait éclaté une
fusillade qui a fait près de 100 morts
et plus de 150 blessés parmi les tp
minutes
après la fusillade
c'est un déferlement de violence de
nombreux européens sont lynchés
la france laisse aussi derrière elle des
dizaines de milliers de harkis ces
supplétifs de l'armée française qui
s'était engagé du côté du colonisateur
des traîtres pour le fln
ils ont volontairement laissé sur place
certains disent qu'on en débatte
changeant du banc elles ont été
abandonnées
ensuite ce qu'ils en la patrie si la
remise à lattaquié il est tombé dans des
camps
qu'ils ont mis dans du contenu quoi
donner un job
donné des instructions pour qu'on
n'embarque pas nerfs qu
il avait dit cercle c'est des gens qui
veut nous [__] la pagaille en france
je ne veux pas qu'ils reviennent
bagis je m'appelle selon ali
mohamed flou y a cru qu'il pourrait
rester il a passé six années en prison
avant de réussir à rejoindre la france
[Musique]
je croyais au cours de mois je crois que
c'est garanti par exemple si je vienne
ici en france j'ai le droit dernier ma
femme mes enfants par exemple n'est pas
ma mère est pas mes frères et pas me
suis
dit
[__] ça va je le reste 19 ans
22 july 62 pour le montre prison il ya
des mois riad et
la majorité est morte
dit good il l'abandonné les acquis sur
lui qu'ils ont et qu'ils envoient nous
au couloir de la mois les accords
d'evian s'il marque la fin de la guerre
d'algérie ne seront pas reconnues par le
futur pouvoir algérien et notamment par
les militaires qui voit la marque d'une
persistance du colonialisme côté
français ils n'auront été que le moyen
de sortir d'une guerre devenu bien trop
impopulaire
voilà les accords d'evian voilà
sept ou huit pages tout cela c'était un
projet magnifique qui aurait pu entrer
en vigueur dans les années 40-50
peut-être 60 mais ça a été gâchée par en
effet des hésitations des reculs de
crime des deux côtés
les algériens ont conquis leur
indépendance et sur les visages d'une
jeunesse radieuse on peut lire alors
tous les espoirs d'une nation naissante
quant à la société multiculturelle
promise dans les accords d'evian elle
n'aura existé que sur quelques pages
d'un document auquel personne ne croyait
vraiment
un document de carême yahiaoui jorge
dias bec et nesrine ben zemmouchi merci
d'avoir suivi cette émission rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de reporter toujours sur france
24 et france 24 points comme
[Musique]